[موسيقى]
تنمر عليه زملائه في الدراسه ولم ينجح في
تكوين صداقات حقيقيه
فخذلته المدرسه
واحتضنته السينما ليصبح نجما من نجوم
الشاشه الكبيره واحد اعلى ممثليه هوليود
اجرا فمن هو راين جوسلينغ
ولد
عام 1980 في كندا والدته سكرتيره ووالده
بائع متجول
اثناء مرحله الدراسه الابتدائيه 10 ايام
معاناه كبيره حيث قام اصدقائه بالمدرسه
بتخويفه مرارا فلم ينجح في تكوين صداقات
وكان يعاني من صعوبه في التركيز اثناء
الفصل استنادا لاصابته باعراض اضطراب فرط
الحركه ونقص الانتباه كما انه بلغ العاشره
وهو يعاني من صعوبه في القراءه
كمن فصل والده وهو في الثالث عشر فقررت
والدته ريان ترك وظيفتها وتعليمه في
المنزل
بعدها التحق بمدرسه ثانويه مهنيه وهناك
ظهرت لديه مهارات الابداع في الدراما
والفنون الجميله ولانه لم يغرم بالدراسه
فقد بدا شقه طريقه نحو عالم الفن وبدا
يبحث عن الفرص حتى تمكن من التقديم كمغنن
في برنامج مسابقات منزل المواهب كما شارك
في اختبارات للمسلسل التلفزيوني ذا ميكي
ماوس كلوب عام
1993 عندما كان في الثانيه عشر من عمره
فقط
وبقى حينها عقدا للعمل ضمن المسلسل لمده
عامين بدور ماوس كثير وحين انتقل الى
ولايه فلوريدا
بعد هذه التجربه عاد ريان الى كندا ومثل
في عده عروض تلفزيونيه مثل
دارك يونج
قبل ان ينتقل وهو في 19 من عمره الى
هوليود لخوض تجربه اكبر
اما الدور الذي جعل اسمه يتردد في الاوساط
الفنيه فكان اداءه لدوري يهودي النازي في
الفيلم المثير للجدل ده بليفر عام 2001
حيث لاستحسانا كبيرا وفاز عنه بجائزه لجنه
التحكيم الكبرى في سن دانس فيلم وبجائزه
الحمل الذهبي من النقابات الروسيه لنقاد
السينما
في عام 2002 كان يؤدي دور البطوله في فيلم
ميردر باي نمبرز وهو الفيلم الذي حقق 56
مليون دولار وشكل بدايه لمسييرته المهنيه
الحافله
في عام 2004 لعب رايان دور البطوله في
فيلم مقتبس عن روايه
الرومانسيه وافرا ذلك حصل على لقب نجم
الغد لممثل السينما وصل ريال الى قمه
مهنته بادائه في فيلم
عام 2006 ثم توالت الادوار الناجحه له
فظهر في العديد من الافلام المتميزه مثل
مانيبول ذا بول اوف ذا فويس
خلال عام 2016
قدم ريان اكثر من 36 عمل ناجحا حصل بفضلها
على اكثر من ترشيحا لجائزه الاوسكار وفاز
بعدد كبير من الجوائز من اهمها
وبعد ان كان لا يحظى باحترام زملائه في
الدراسه وبلا اصدقاء اصبح نجما محبوبا وفي
رصيده ثروه تقدر ب 70 مليون دولار
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]